change lives change organizations change
the world
I'm honored to be on this historic and
exceedingly beautiful campus indeed over
the span of more than 120 years the name
of Stanford has become synonymous with
innovation and quality it has become the
symbol of global leadership in so many
areas pioneering scientific research
conducted here has contributed to the
development of many technological
inventions from microchip to Internet
you know better than I that they have
all profoundly changed our life I am
sure that if the matter of pride for
Stanford that many of the leading global
technology firms from Google to Yahoo
Cisco system and hewlett-packard were
began with ideas and research spawned
here at Stanford so this university is a
cradle of creative destruction an engine
of globalization it is one of the
reasons why the United States has been
and probably long will be a global
leader in innovation Science and
Technology Stanford has never ceased
seeking the better it has always been
able to adapt to the changes in our
world as much as it shaped the change
for that reason it's a great honor to
address an institution that leads
constructive global change and nurtures
the leaders of change their guests today
I was asked to speak about leadership by
sharing my experience with you
I'm pretty sure as members of the
graduate of the business school you are
very much familiar with the traits of a
leader but I would say this whoever we
are today is the result of many choices
that he made through our lives the
failures we suffered the chances we had
the talents we obtained at birth and the
skills we develop during our lives
journey but sometimes destiny works out
irrespective of what we are made of for
instance I was born in town named after
Julius Caesar called Kaiser II on the
29th of October which in Turkey is known
as a republic day when we celebrate the
founding of the Turkish Republic the
29th of October is for us but the 4th of
July is for the Americans Kaiser is
renowned for its entrepreneurs in the
sense Kaiser has been the line stand of
Turkish atropine airship so it was a
well-established tradition in Kaiser for
families to recruit the most intelligent
and talented children for their business
there is long been a practice in Kaiser
that when a ball and finished primary
school families would test his business
tickets before sending him to secondary
high school they usually put him in a
friend shop to see how he might behave
whether he is active and clever or if he
is shy and unassertive if the boy
appears to be capable the parents will
most often engage the boy in business
life right away if the boy is not very
good in marketing they send him to
further
I remember I was tested to my
grandfather's shop was very crowded in
those years and even on the street there
were crowds that I had to sell bottle of
soda in the buckets filled with eyes one
day my uncle came by grandfather's shop
to examine my business seekers he took a
bottle of soda
open it and shouted loudly ice-cold soda
ice-cold soda makes all 32 teams play
the wider it is the same it was an
effective marketing strategy in those
days with his powerful voice my uncle
got the attention of the people around
the store and sold many sodas on the
spot then he forced me to do the same
but I was too shy to shout like him and
failed miserably in selling sodas of
course that was the end of my business
career in that very failure would not
have happened that day most probably I'd
not be the president of the Turkish
Republic today of course that I've been
successful in selling sodas I'd be much
richer now a lot a lot like most of my
fellow Kaiser a businessman so the
leadership sometimes comes out of
failure in fact in our life failures are
important because they leave us with
difficult but viable choices we the role
lessons from our failures and work
harder to succeed in our endeavor for my
part I studied hard in school since I
knew that education was the most
efficient enabler
for me to achieve a better life
distinguished guests good leaders must
be sure also possess god-given traits
however I believe in most cases
leadership is a nurtured phenomenon
rather than a gift of nature effective
leaders must love to learn change and
expand if we are not learning maturing
changing or expanding then you cannot
expect the people to believe in you and
follow you in my life I always believed
that there is room for learning change
and innovation I personally learned a
lot when I worked at Islamic Development
Bank for eight years in Jeddah Saudi
Arabia where I was able to get
accustomed to social economic problems
at the potential of the Islamic world
that experience had a huge impact on my
political makeup and region later on
unexpectedly and to a certain extent
reluctantly I found myself in portals
when I was convinced to run for MP seat
from my hometown kaiser ii in 1991 as a
member of parliament I serve as the
Council of Europe Parliamentary Assembly
for almost a decade through that
experience I learned and digest the
fundamentals of democratic politics and
European values which are widely
accepted universal norms for democracy
human rights and the rule of law that
again had an enormous effect on my
political mindset and region today I am
sure you all must know the same to
change the world begin with yourselves
the unprecedented velocity of change has
made one thing and absolute
priority for today's decision-makers the
ability to adopt to this dynamic global
system today as political leaders we are
faced with infinitely complex challenges
with global ramifications and in the
face of to these fluid dynamics of
global order the role of leaders has
gained EQ and particular importance
indeed it is only through strong and
regional leadership that we can see
through these uncharted waters in other
words this area is one that needs
leaders to leaders who can understand
the transformation taking place and
quickly adapt to the fast changing
environment
leaders must also be fulfilled by
envisioning and inspiring destinations
and by charting and arresting the calls
to get there
this requires imagination and a broad
vision after all leadership is all about
vision a leader should create region
expresses region and pursue his vision
until he drives it to accomplishment
most importantly he has forget others
engage in his region supporting his
region and rallying around his vision on
other hand a leader should not always
seek the easy and well-worn path ahead
he or she should be ready to go and give
direction and leave a trail behind it is
obvious that the world is better off
with leaders who have more dreams and
fevered nightmares among others Martin
Luther King's dreams in the myths of
social nightmares helped make America
what it is today
distinguished guests
a leader must also be in full harmony
with the people who follow him and be
capable of responding to their
aspirations in fact for the first time
in human history more than half of the
nations are governed by democratic
governments therefore it's today almost
a universally accepted notion that the
only source of legitimacy for a
political leader is the people's choice
and every day and everywhere we are
seeing increasing involvement of people
in decision-making we saw this entire
square in Egypt as well as among the
walls it demonstrators in New York this
is the age of people's empowerment of
course this is a good thing for
democracy and in fact unavoidable given
its natural course however there is a
paradox here under increasing public
pressure the leaders might become likely
to take bold decisions for the common
good which may not always be popular
this point is particularly pertinent the
times of economic difficulties and in
the midst of deep-rooted political
conflicts the current situation in
Europe is a telling example of how the
lack of visionary leadership could
adversely affected lives of millions
first Europe's leaders failed should be
to see the looming economic problems and
to take bold steps in addressing them
with leadership necessities fixing the
roof when the Sun is still shining
consequently the limitation of the
European leaders in taking necessary
decisions did bring about the financial
calamities they currently
and now confronted with the severe
crisis there are growing tendencies
across Europe to become more introverted
and to give in to the rise of extremist
political groups indeed in recent months
we have witnessed in one after another
election far-right parties gained
explain and even worse
their ideologies at views are more and
more becoming part of the mainstream
this is certainly another good example
of leadership but petty politics at its
worst another area where we witnessed a
tragic failure of leadership is in the
Middle East where leaders have wont been
out of touch with their people in need
the leaders of the countries like
Tunisia Libya Egypt Yemen and Syria have
been utterly unable to see the growing
global forces driven by the innovations
nurtured here at the University at the
Silicon Valley innovation in
communications and social media allow
everyone to learn about what's happening
elsewhere in the world and makes
comparisons in fact these perhaps one of
the greatest contribution Stanford has
made enabling the transformation of
freedom democracy and development in the
world because of your innovations no
regime today has the luxury to govern
its people behind iron curtains these
dictators don't thought they could stay
in power as long as their armies and
intelligence were strong even when
citizens revolt started these leaders
continued to follow the apparently
Universal Manning of dictators and try
to press the people by sheer force
in my last letter to President Assad of
Syria last year in August when the
events could be handled at a relatively
low humanitarian cost I told him very
clearly that people in the streets will
not go away by ignorant or repression I
said that it's time to show leadership
and to lead the change by undertaking
the necessary reforms to address the
legitimate aspiration of the people
before it is too late unfortunately
today the cause of people dying in Syria
nearly nearly every day and we see that
everything is really too late and they
are doing something they are the two
little distinguished guests another
important aspect of leadership is of
course talented fruit at the right time
in the right place no matter how
inconvenient the truth is when I ran for
my party's leadership in the year 2000 I
had to tell my fellow party members that
the way we were conducting politics was
anachronistic and irrelevant tannic this
truth was extremely risky at that time
when the funnik leader openly favor my
rival and it was the party tradition not
to challenge the leaders choices
although I was defeated at the party
convention by a slight margin I was able
to get my message across first party
constituents and delegates attend to the
large Society in Turkey in fact debt
reform and innovation there even
strategy and narrative laid the ground
work for the establishment of the
Justice and Development Party
we called a gay party in 2001 at
international level I dare to tell
similar fruit to my fellow colleagues
from the Islamic world as early as 2003
I myself made a strong appeal to the
leaders of the Organization of Islamic
Cooperation countries at the meeting in
patran I stress to them that they must
all undertaken necessary reforms in
order to be comfortable with the
universal democratic values I also want
them of the dire consequences of failing
to do so so for me the Arab Spring was
not a surprise at all but just the
replay of history and a long and and and
a logical expression of the ultimate
aspiration of the human beings ladies
and gentlemen a good leader has to be
patient and prudent however sometimes a
leader must take risks and my own test
with taking risk of course in foreign
relations came especially when I visited
Arab on the capital of Armenia upon the
invitation of the Armenian president
ostensibly the mutation was to attend a
football match with the president but it
was much more than that
for the leaders of two neighboring
nations that had profound disagreements
about our shared history it was a risky
move for democratic report domestic
political consideration and it might
have been very risky for foreign policy
implication as well I went to Yerevan
marking the first ever visit of a
Turkish president to Armenia the reward
I was expecting from this gesture was a
Manning of
Frances between our two nations I city
perceive this hope our mutual
presidential visits will continue to be
a symbol of hope for the normalization
of Turkish and Armenian relations risky
as it was I did the right thing by
visiting Yerevan which brings to mind
something the Peter Drucker once said
management is doing things right
leadership is doing the right things if
it is necessary a good leader should
also be able to make difficult decisions
and painful concessions you may well
remember that all the stuff at the start
of the World War two Winston Churchill
taught the British people that he
promised nothing but blood toil tears
and sweat in the face of extension
threat to his country in the meantime a
good leader should never lose sight of
being a dealer in hope for the people no
matter how desperate circumstances are
by with his Star Wars and stole to
resolve churches successfully right his
people the defender at the end the free
world the hope he gave to his citizens
was certainly a white ingredients of
their survival victory and honor when I
took the position of Prime Minister in
Turkey in 2002 we face enormous
challenges we were at the head of an
economic crisis that started in the year
2001 when we lost one third of our
nation's income all night there was also
a looming war in Iraq and we were at the
crossroad of negotiations on Cyprus
and turkeys in your membership prospects
all those problems require us to make
difficult decisions and significant
compromises all those years we work
together with under the eyes and she
knows very well those difficult years
and dates being aware of that leader
must have a plan to materialize his
vision I laid down a comprehensive
long-term plan covering all policy
measures in the judicial economic and
political domains in this plan I did not
fall into trap of satisfying short-term
populist demands instead I focused on
the long-term interest of the nations
with this understanding the aka party
government's strictly implemented our
plan and fortunately all those difficult
choice paid off thanks to those majors
for instance despite the economic crisis
across Europe Turkey stands out as the
second fastest growing economy in the
world right after China and if torch
democracy somehow functions as a source
of inspiration for people in the Middle
East again this was because of the
reforms taken by the government's since
2002 when we were taking these painful
measures at the time we were also giving
hope to our nation for achieving better
democracy a well-functioning market
economy and an active and assertive
foreign policy on all front as a result
of these reforms Turkey today is more
pluralistic inclusive and tolerant than
ever before that said we are also aware
that there is room for further
improvement in the field of personal
freedoms
as such we are under no such illusion
that our task is improving our democracy
is over
a leader must have a fair and realistic
assessment about the shortcomings of his
country or organization as the president
of Turkey I know very well that we still
have a long way to go in broadening the
liberties as maintaining the civilian
pillars of our democracy but there is
widespread agreement across the spectrum
in 30 dead
we must further develop our democratic
standards towards that and we are now in
the process of drafting a new
constitution with the active
participation of all political parties
NGOs
professional associations universities
think tanks intellectuals as well as
ordinary citizens this include inclusive
approach to Constitution writing is also
important for the development of a
culture of compromise which I believe is
the backbone of matric democracy
parallel to Turkey's profound political
transformation we have enacted
across-the-board economic reforms with
tight financial discipline these were
very tough and not highly popular
choices at the time
thanks to these structural reforms the
resilience of the Turkish economy has
now been boosted against major external
shocks as a result turkey has become the
16th largest economy in the world with a
GDP of more than 1 trillion in u.s.
dollars turkeys development policy is a
great attentive elements to as we all
know science technology and innovation
are essential elements for nations that
aspire for a better
future in this regard turkey has made
great strides in recent years to us
becoming a knowledge-based economy
research and development expenditures
have increased threefold in the past 10
years this growth rate in our NT
expenditures has almost been four times
higher than the OECD and eu27 averages
during the same period the number of
Turkish international patent
applications has increased by more than
300 percent
moreover the ratio of Internet users is
one of the highest in the region and yet
fastest growing in the world Turkey has
the fourth largest number of Facebook
users globally for instance last but not
least we now help 173 universities in
Turkey 89 of them have opened since 2006
in a nutshell these statistics suggest
that we have been heavily investing in
education science and technology to
raise the future leaders of Turkey we
are undergoing nothing less than a
profound transformation distinguished
guests there is another important
aspects of the leadership not individual
leadership but collective leadership
institutionalized leadership leadership
does not necessarily depend on a single
person or a single country if we can
instant slice institutionalized
leadership then we will more likely a
better global governance in fact today
the state of affairs of the
international system is rather
problematic there is a growing consensus
that we now needed written global
governance structures to address new
risk such as widening income disparity
among nations and poverty
the apparent weakness of our global
financial architecture and cultural
polarization which besides no nation
however self-sufficient or strong it may
be is capable of coping with the
complexity of today's world alone in
such an environment unilateral actions
or remedies are providing to be not only
less and less effective but also
increasingly anachronistic effective
global governance requires
institutionalized collective leadership
through reform organizations such as the
UN and g20 into this globalizing world
where fast-paced change is engulfing the
entire community of nations from every
conceivable direction leadership is not
an easy task
it's and gentlemen dear students Turkey
will not relent in trying to lead our
own nation and others as both as
positively as we can as the leader of
dynamic country whose experience is
transforming itself is being watched
closely by a wide audience I myself also
feel the responsibility to lead by
example therefore I will continue to
press both at home and abroad for a more
pluralistic and inclusive democracy more
sustainable development more collective
security and more intercultural and
inter-religious tolerance as someone who
came out of a medium-sized Anatolian
town my whole life has been a constant
struggle seeking a better life at war
for my fellow countrymen there have been
times when it was difficult even to stay
afloat but I always followed my hopes
and dreams and never fell in despair so
far in my speech I am characterized the
air we are going through as one of
change innovation
commitment cooperation people's
empowerment and leadership throughout
all my life these were precisely the
notions and principles that guide me too
I always been attracted to my
conservative and traditional values
nevertheless my cultural identity and
tall's conservative values did not
inhibit me from adapting to the
ever-changing realities of the world I
have tried to be modest
tolerant and humble in my political
discourse and paid utmost attention to
adopting a constructive political
language I have been prudent patient
perseverance and pragmatic in most of my
professional political and diplomatic
dealings but on the essential matters
when my principles clash with pragmatic
opportunity my instinct always goes with
the principles and I will fight for
principles to the end
Anette regard I was put to test when I
ran for the presidential office despite
all the unfair and and artificial
pressure inflicted upon me to decline my
nomination I pursued my vision and sided
with my principles speaking from
personal experience all I can leave with
you today is the strong but simply
advice simple advice that you never shy
away from taking responsibility and that
you lead when you can graduating from
Stanford it will always be equipped with
the necessary tools to succeed as
leaders Stanford graduates before you
have done so much to change the world
however we expect more from you in
finding solutions to global problems
such as poverty global warming energy
security
biological security I firmly believe
that with your outstanding leadership
called 12 qualities and culture of
innovative entrepreneurship you will
make an enormous difference in the
resolution of these global problems to
again thank you for the invitation to be
here and I wish all you the best thank
you very much
thank you for me for Tamaki
president join me yes well thank you
very much for that wonderful address
about leadership and you have given us
both many opportunities to think about
leadership and about the global picture
and so if I may I would like to start
with a question of the global picture
and then we will open to our audience
mr. president Turkey is democratizing
the ake a party is a party that is a
party of values it is an Islamist party
but within a democratic context what
would you say to those who say that it
is not possible for there to be
democracy within the Islamic world what
would you say to people who say that
Egypt will have to choose between Islam
and democracy and I know that there are
some people they think that Islam and
democracy are contradictory these two
don't go together but Turkey is the
nineties Turkey the church people the
most most majority they are Muslim and
freed practiced what they believe and
democracy is functioning very well now
as I said we are aware our shortcomings
definitely there is no perfect democracy
never where there are problems heroes
are there are problems in America in in
in Europe so we have some problems but
the main principle of democracy is
functioning in Turkey turkey is a
democratic secular country and there's a
freedom as I said in my speech
particularly since 2002 we have been
taking real reforms political and
economic
forms we are shaping the country in a
new times so that's why turkey became a
source of inspiration for many other
Muslims they are questioning their
leaders they are saying that look
turkeys a Muslim country and
historically that was the leading
country the Islamic world once we
inherited our history legacy and our
identity is well known by at the same
time Turkey is negotiating for the full
membership with Europe EU turkey is the
part of European custom Union and the
democracy is getting the event deep in
Turkey
again I mentioned in my speech that now
we are writing a new constitution this
new constitution all the people that are
engaged all the NGOs all the
universities whoever has something she
has something to say these are all
listen to now the committee is writing
with in this direction so I'm sure that
in near future we will see more
countries Muslim identity Muslim
population and democracy is flourishing
there also from the audience do we have
questions in the audience
we have some here and you'll pass the
microphone please stand up if you will
hi mr. president
my name is Marty Zach I'm a sophomore
and an undergraduate at Stanford and
amidst the tumult of the Arab Spring two
countries that have stayed relatively
stable or your own Turkey and also
Israel and I'm curious
how you see that relationship going
forward since traditionally it's been a
pillar of regional security and
stability and particularly in this time
of upheaval I've been receiving this
kind of questions and recently I know
that many friends of Israel and Turkey
they are not happy with the current
station but they must know that this was
not our preferences it's because of the
Israeli government you know when the
International mentoring aid convoy was
going to have to cut the people from
more than 30 countries there were people
in the ships they were attacked on the
high seas 72 miles away from the coast
and killed nine people aid of the under
Turkish than other one Turkish American
citizens so when that happened if two
companies are friend you expect that the
other should say apology and compensate
this so this is the very legitimate
expectation of the Turkish people
unfortunately so far they have not done
this I hope that they understand as you
know two democracies in the region and
we had good cooperation in fact we were
working together for the peace we have a
lot once
through our efforts design and surely
we're about to start the direct talks
for the peace but unfortunately these
were not appreciated that that happened
so I hope that the mistake is understood
that some appropriate steps are taken
and again the relationship mr. president
you mentioned Syria in this answer can
you talk a little bit about Syria Turkey
has been very active in trying to bring
an end to the humanitarian disaster and
to point a way forward for a more
pluralistic Syria can you talk just a
little bit about and perhaps the next
person who has a question can get ready
to get a microphone will come over here
yes condi first of all Turkey and Syria
although we have 900 kilometer border
the tree is not - bilateral issue it is
the humanitarian issue when Arab Spring
started the Syrian people also became
gorgeous and the fear is gone and people
demanded freedom democracy and these are
the legitimate right of the people so
when they were in the street
unfortunately regime sent a tanks
soldiers and keep the people the south
it started now unfortunate it's too late
you should control the kings
we tried a lot before we wish that
President Assad leads the change under
his leadership Syria transforms because
we used to talk with him you remember
all those years we were telling him that
there is no
any more place in on the cost of the
material for the authoritarian regimes
one-party rules because the Syrian young
generation Syrian people they are
monitoring every corner of the world
they are knowing that how the people are
enjoying their rights in other countries
so it's their legitimate right so they
wanted when you don't pay the attention
you don't listen to them and send
soldier weapons kills people then of
course they evolve it's the right so
that's happening you know it's in the UN
Security Council there is a 6-point an
unplanned there we wish that that plan
is fully with all its aspect it is
implant implemented if it is implemented
then that can be the orderly way for the
orderly transformation in Syria
as far as Turkey is concerned since we
are border we have security problems so
far we are hosting 25,000 sick refugees
from Syria and in any time thousands
might come to Turkey this happened once
during the first Gulf War in 1991 in two
years 500,000 people from northern Iraq
they had to run into Turkey when the
Saddam seen used chemical weapons in
collection so there is a danger there so
therefore we are more vigilant for
democracy in our neighbor country south
my name is a son
I'm a third year master's student at the
IPS international security program
it was Immanuel Kant that dubbed
international trade as one of the basis
of Perpetual peace and a century and a
half later was the Bretton Woods system
that actually tried to attempt to
bolster security and peace in light of
this and the changes of sis Micmac unit
magnitude in North America in North
Africa and the Middle East how do you
see the chances of Turkey tapping into
his foreign trade credentials to set up
some sort of perpetual peace in the
region
thank you you know we have historical
relationship with these countries so
always there's a separate it was Turkey
their part in North Africa more
countries and when the move started we
made historical choice and we said that
we'll be together with the people this
was also received very well by the
people of course this change is not easy
change because the people they spend the
years under the leadership so there is
no any establishment leadership enough
so this will be painful of course but I
believe that at the end I think we'll
continue on the correct course at the
direction and the trend is going well
and the result will be good between
Turkey and these countries Economic
Cooperation is also very much important
for instance in Egypt there are church
industrial zones there is one in Cairo
seventy thousand people are employed
there and during the difficult days all
the factories they were open
at the people also they own them I see
most of the difficulty in this change is
the economic side because during the
political transformation and some case
turmoil the economies might get weak
although still they are giving weak but
they might be even worse so therefore
all of us we have to help them and
Turkey particularly paying attention on
economic cooperation between these
countries we are sending trade missions
we are sending investors to those
countries to make investment and to
carry know how technology and where
concrete visible things are happening so
I think this is the most important
contribution to those country Turkey's
accent mr. president I'm sure that the
audience here the students the faculty
the Stanford family will join me in
thanking you very much for spending the
time with us you have in your family a
member of the Stanford Faculty of that
Stanford family and so you are always
welcome here in the university and all
the best to you thank you very much
please join us
change why
the lives change organizations diabetes
organizations change the world